we got e4
have i got a lot of black games today i
feel like i have
an old ratty favorite of mine
of mine sorry
see if my opponent's got something in
store
just h3 huh i don't know about this one
here i feel like i'm getting decent play
sort of fringe like structure
but i haven't yet locked up my bishop
on c8 which i think should be
should be a bit of an advantage
not to like give me an advantage but
advantage compared to
through normal french positions
a4 interesting i guess intending bishop
3 at some point
what must have been a mouse slip right
really really cheeky enough to
just hide the king away on f1
intending to
intending to attack me in a very brutal
way with h4 and so on
don't believe though don't believe it
okay i wasn't sure about bishop f6
rook h6 so i prefer this i can stack the
exchange
queens no i don't like that
also i'm thinking here h4 i'm gonna go
bishop g4 which looks comfortable enough
so i think my opponent should take the
game along more positional lines with
let's say bishop e5 instead
then probably bishop f5 and i have a
good game
but only because he's got king f1
otherwise i wouldn't have been so
optimistic
queen d2
what's that all about can't i just win a
pawn now
i don't see why not bishop g6
it's tricky but then i got rook f3
f9 d4 bishop d4 bishop g6 i got bishop
a1 but
more importantly i got rook f2 winning
the queen
so i believe it's just losing a pawn
okay can't resist the chance to play
with a bit of a flourish right
i think this should work
a rookie seven
that is
that is a
surprising move
not sure if it's a great move
bishop f6 looks good
for a moment there i thought my opponent
had come up with
one of the most gangster cheapos i've
seen in a long time
but i don't think so
i think i'm just winning
queen e3 i got 96
adding on insult to injury by trapping
his
his rook
the rook is stuck in enemy territory
and will be executed by midnight
queen b6 just playing it pragmatically
exchanging those
bishop
queens
b6 i guess e5 or just take it
basically i'm a rook up and i'm gonna
convert no matter what
there's a checkmaster unless your
opponent
your point was rook c6 rook c6 basically
e4
skewering skewering the rooks but
unfortunately even
after that you will be above down and by
pawns queening